as sam wilson aka the falcon anthony
mackie plays a lean mean mcu fighting
machine
even before his debut in captain america
the winter soldier mackie has pretty
much been in exceptional shape
so how did he get so ripped we've got
all the details
anthony mackie threw his hat into the
marble ring in the early 2010s but it
would be a while before he got the suit
up as the falcon
in that time he made a movie with two of
the most ripped actors in hollywood
mark wahlberg and the rock himself
dwayne johnson mackie had to hit the
weights hard for his role in michael
bay's pain and gain
which was very loosely based on a
real-life kidnapping executed by some
ham-fisted bodybuilders in the 1990s
by mackie's own admission he was quote
lazy and fat when he landed the part of
steroid using meathead
adrian doorball telling buzzfeed i was
looking for a project to help me get
back in the gym and start working out
and i'm sitting down curling twinkies
and watching prices right every morning
mackie was given just five weeks to get
in shape for the shoot to make that
happen he started a regimen of heavy
lifting and no
cardio he told men's help i was max
repping i was doing chest and thighs
back and tries and shoulders
and then friday would be legs and i
would start over again it was just
constantly ripping the muscle giving it
four days to recover and then going
right back into it
to help him get ripped for pain and gain
mackie enlisted the help of an old
workout buddy back in his hometown of
new orleans
he told buzzfeed we would just push each
other every day then once the movie
started mark and i would work out every
morning together
mackie has spoken at length about what
it was like having mark wahlberg as a
workout partner for the duration of the
shoot
he revealed that the musician turned
hollywood star quotes can be very
difficult at times but he doesn't hold
that against him
telling vibe the thing about mark is
that he is the ultimate competitor
i thought that i was competitive but
he's a definite rival in my level of
competitiveness
that's it work harder keeping up with
wahlberg and his iron pumping entourage
proved to be quite the challenge but it
did absolute wonders for the soon-to-be
marvel star's physique they spent around
six weeks as gym buddies and mackie
noticed some extreme gains in that time
saying we would push each other to the
limits and max out it was a great
opportunity to be in the gym and just
become a gym head like i was in high
school once again
mackie's dream of joining the mcu became
a reality when he won the role of the
falcon and captain america the winter
soldier but he quickly realized that he
was going to look tiny next to the super
jack to chris evans
the hard work he did before and during
the making of pain and gain had him in
impressive shape
but this was another level entirely
don't say it don't you say come on
after news of his casting broke mackie
told vulture chris evans is in such good
shape i'm just a duty dragged into the
lab that he injected with some
but i gotta stand next to him so we
shall see at that point everything
mackie knew about the falcon came from
the comics and they made for a pretty
daunting read
describing sam wilson a harlem-born
orphan who becomes captain america's
partner after the latter freezed his
mind from the control of the red skull
mackie said he's known for his physique
he's described as 6'3
245 pounds so starting monday for the
next five months until we start shooting
i'm going back to high school workouts
and start doing two a days so i get up
to 230 pounds
he may not look quite as jacked as evans
does in captain america the winter
soldier but by the time they reunited to
shoot avengers age voltron mackie was
apparently doing more push-ups than even
cap himself
every superhero actor wants to look
their best when they pull on their
costume and anthony mackie is no
exception
a competitive person by nature he
instinctively started comparing himself
to chris evans after joining the cast of
captain america the winter soldier
though he knew that sam wilson isn't a
super soldier like cap
this meant that he had to toe a fine
line between looking super jacked and
superhuman
he told vibe i wanted to put myself in a
position where i don't look like mr t
but you can tell that the guy works out
and pays attention to his physique and
is healthy
i've been in the gym and worked out long
enough to know how to get results with
my body
he got those results with the aid of
some good old-fashioned shut-eye and a
carefully considered diet
oh hi guess what i'm doing i'm cooking
to this day the actor is very particular
about what he eats while he's bulking up
when he sat down with men's health in
2021 he revealed that his personally
designed meal plan helps him to quote
lean out for the camera i find that
because i lift heavy i tend to bulk
easily so i try to use my diet to cut as
much fat as possible
coffee has long been america's favorite
source of caffeine but all joe has had a
new rival in recent years
energy drinks have become a popular
alternative to more expensive
pre-workout beverages
with one study from the journal of the
international society of sports
nutrition revealing that 42 percent of
athletes chug one as part of their
regimen
mackie has never been interested though
telling men's health i'm not really
really big on pre-workout or energy
drinks
i feel like i don't need the boost so i
try to drink as much water as possible
before and after going to the gym
it does however partake in another
favorite of bodybuilders everywhere
the protein shake the actor began
consuming a shake after every workout
during his pain and gain days
telling buzzfeed i would do half a
banana a scoop of peanut butter and a
scoop of protein with skim milk and make
a smoothie
and he's been fine-tuning his recipe
ever since nowadays he's less about the
peanuts and more about the almond
telling men's health i do a scoop of
vegan-based protein a tablespoon of
powdered almond butter so it cuts all
the sugar out of it i do almond milk and
almond water he also uses collagen and
turmeric which he claims helps with
elasticity and joint repair
my big thing now is a collagen
mackie got used to getting up early to
eat back when he was working out with
mark wahlberg telling the pittsburgh
post gazette that he would have six egg
whites and an egg yolk for breakfast at
6am
speaking of honey and lime about the
strict diet he followed for captain
america the winter soldier mackie said
you know fitness is a lifestyle you have
to eat a certain way you have to do a
certain thing you have to live a certain
way
the falcon still has eggs in the morning
but he cooks them up nowadays
mackie told men's health that his quote
real simple breakfast is usually made up
of six scrambled eggs with sauteed
onions or sweet peppers
he also has a portion of steel-cut oats
a breakfast favorite among bodybuilders
adding this deal cut oats is very
important because my body uses those
carbs to burn off when i work out in the
morning
because i like to work out early that's
the breakfast i have every day
from the moment he gets up in the
morning to the end of the day mackie is
quote constantly grazing in the kitchen
telling men's health i'll nibble and
bite and eat throughout the course of
the day so i never feel full
but i never feel empty that doesn't mean
he skimps on the portions at meal time
however
he follows up his egg and oat breakfast
with a pretty big lunch that's full of
everything he needs to keep his
superhero bod
according to mackie that includes two or
three grilled chicken cutlets some cut
vegetables with hummus and a salad
i try to have my big meals in the middle
of the day instead of
later the extra food he puts away at
lunch time gives him the energy he needs
to carry on until the evening when he
does a three mile 30 minute run to get
the blood pumping
it's more functional than it is tasty
but that's all part of the gig
mackie got used to saying goodbye to the
naughty things in his life when he was
preparing for captain america the winter
soldier
joking to honey and lime me and my
homeboy jack daniels stopped talking
me and my girlfriend haagen-dazs broke
up she french it was crazy so it goes
for those who want to portray
superheroes
mackie's fellow marvel star chris
hemsworth has proven that it's perfectly
possible to achieve a god-like body
while on a plant-based diet
the thor actor shocked everyone his own
personal trainer included when he
managed to maintain his incredible
physique after going vegan
there's a lot to be said for vegan
superheroes but that's not how macky
rolls
the actor revealed to men's health that
he's a big meat lover saying
dinner is usually a big piece of fish or
a piece of chicken i try to stay with
lean protein i'm really into bison and
buffalo now if i have to have red meat
or lamb which is my favorite meat on
earth he went on to reveal that every
now and then he'll visit his favorite
butcher in search of quote
something wild to spice things up like
rabbit or something like that
becky pairs his meat with either brown
rice or quinoa saying
quinoa is really big for me now so i'll
do that and make a quinoa veggie saute
after debuting as the falcon and captain
america the winter soldier anthony
mackie went on to reprise the role in
avengers age of ultron ant-man
captain america civil war avengers
infinity war and avengers end game
by the time it came to film end game he
had his fitness regimen down to an art
when the actor sat down for a video
interview with vanity fair right after
the release of the multi-billion dollar
grossing sequel in 2019
he walked viewers through his typical
day i wake up to beyonce
i do i love beyonce she makes me strong
she's my spirit animal after that he
eats his protein-packed breakfast and
that's when hard work begins
according to the actor the first thing i
do in the morning is 100 push-ups
around 7 30 am he hits the gym mackie
also shared a big workout hack
instead of driving himself to the gym
and warming up there he runs the four
miles instead leaving him with more time
for weights
get in i'm already warm from the jog
mackie says he always begins with
30 minutes of legs then we move on to
other places monday is chest and try
tuesday will be back and biceps every
day you hit abs for 20 minutes
and then wednesday would be legs and
shoulders burn them out start the
routine over
at this point atlanta is a second home
to marvel stars like anthony mackie
at least a dozen mcu movies have made
use of pinewood atlanta studios and the
atlanta metro area has doubled for
everywhere from new york city to lagos
disney plus series the falcon and the
winter soldier was also filmed in
atlanta
and when mackie wasn't on the job he
liked to slip into his favorite pair of
cycling shorts and find some exercise
bikes
he told gq you have a lot of different
cycling places
you have the cycling places in buckhead
where you have a lot of young women with
ponytails that'll scream and are very
angry on their bikes
or you can go to the cycling place in
decatur where there are a lot of young
angry people who yell and twerk on bikes
yes it's true i like to listen to
rhythmic music and lift weights while i
ride bikes for
long distances against young women yes
mackie particularly likes getting his
bike fixed in midtown where it's
apparently a lot more easy going
he said it's just a bunch of nice people
that ride bikes no one's yelling no
one's throwing stuff
everyone's sweating the cycling along
with all of mackie's tried and tested
routines reportedly had him in the best
shape of his life as he shot the falcon
and the winter soldier
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one